oh what a show what a show what a show
now listen I know I promised you guys
the new opening titles today okay but I
can't do them today because there's a
little change in the scheduling I had an
unexpected buddy show up and we laid
down a podcast very funny podcast with
my stand-up comedy buddy
Cort McGowan who is just hilarious we
worked together a lot we've been buddies
for a long time and so he dropped in and
today we're talking about all kinds of
things from from crazy creepy crawly
critters to dating - what else we're
going to play too soon or not too soon
the Harland Highway game that we like to
play we're going to be talking about
Instagram and Twitter and and you know
girls with goofy body parts and just
really crazy stuff and we're going to
play some of courts stand-up comedy in
fact what I'm going to do is I'm going
to play a bit for you right out of the
gate here and then we'll drop into the
show this will be the last time you'll
be hearing the title sequence that we've
been using as I said it got moved so
it'll be the next podcast you'll hear
the brand new title so hope you enjoy
this special edition of the Harlan
Highway podcast let's let's start it off
with court McGowan doing a a bit from
his hilarious stand-up comedy album and
then we'll jump right into the show on
the Harland Highway I used to drink like
this that's how I know
I just I just got 13 years clean and
sober you guys forgive you go to class
don't apart I'm gonna have mr. Gaddafi
on me I missed it man I do I do but it's
like but I can't do it I can't I'm a
blackout drinker yeah some of you people
know what I'm talking about yes I've
been some big things up like the 90s you
know I just heard this band Pearl Jam
last week check it out and hold hands
with people and I I don't I don't miss
the Blues as much man I've been smoking
weed or do I miss smoking weed and I'm
jealous now because it's legal now you
guys seem to get little cards let's go
the doctor he likes you stuff your tote
he's like smokes weekend promoter we
didn't have that man you guys I was
watching a special on 60 minutes I was
just [ __ ] truly watching this thing
they're walking into sore it's like sub
sink last jars on shelves it's kind of
swept it's like felt like a [ __ ] wine
tasting people walking on I'll sample
some of that into there I used to have
to meet a guy named Julio the jack in
the bottom part block 1138 I guess
they're paranoid he rides up on a stolen
bicycle pulls a sweaty bag on his ass
crack across to the window
you got your car go [ __ ] yourself that's
all right sit down strap in and tighten
your diaper come on baby
you were about to go down the Heartland
highway why didn't bargain for this oh
yeah it took a job chicka chicka cow
Wayne baby the creature
please don't stop I say magnificent
perform this is the Harlan Highway I
hate you well that's the way it goes
what do you say we get down
[Music]
hey everybody this is Harland Williams
you rolling down the Harlan Highway and
oh my god what a show what a great
summer fest crab fest lobster fest show
yeah I have a very special guest today
give me your all show all however long
it takes 30 minutes hundred minutes I
don't know a great friend of mine great
comedian after all round everything
podcaster he does it all he's here with
us right now ladies and gentlemen court
McGowan Harland Williams how are you
buddy how are you bud I'm good
you're very summery you got the shorts
the shoes with no socks me too yeah well
I play golf this morning oh you did
people don't know about you that you're
you're like a golfer you play with like
really big names you introduced me to a
Rickie Fowler and Freud and Brooks
koepka who just won the US Open a few
years ago you introduced me to them one
night and I don't know anything about
golf and they were like hey can we get a
picture with you Harlan and I was like
yeah wait a few minutes I was busy doing
and then you tell me afterwards you're
like these are like two of the biggest
golfers in the world and then remember
this they he took a picture with me and
you tweeted it and then my Twitter blew
up bigger than it's ever blowing up I
have ever we are driving back to the
hotel and we had to turn our
notifications off because every like two
seconds there was like another
notification he goes he comes down I
whenever I headline La Jolla Comedy
Store I do it the weekend of the PGA
Tour event okay and he always comes to
the show and Rickie Fowler always comes
to show and buy they just let me clarify
you just dropped a little nugget we were
driving back to the hotel that was me in
court we're doing a comedy gig in
Florida and we were driving back to the
hotel to our respective room
we don't we don't sleep together anymore
doing anymore
I know so I just not been set up is that
big Twitter thing that happened in
Florida but uh but no Ricky does Ricky
Kent comes down to the shows and he'll
go an Instagram photo and he'll tweet it
out or he'll put it out on Instagram and
within I kid you not within 30 minutes
he'll have 800,000 life hug and I just
can't imagine what that's like I just
can't imagine that happened to me
recently I was I was warming up for the
caramel corn the Pug special oh that you
helped me with and I was working on you
know you know putting on the mask and
and and working on the caramel corn
character at the Comedy Store one night
and I was in the green room in the back
all alone with Joe Rogan we were in
there for about 15 minutes there's no
one back to the show hasn't started yet
and we were just shooting the breeze Joe
was talking I was talking and then I had
the caramel corn hug mask in a bag and
while he was just kind of talking and
looking at his phone I put the mask on
without saying anything and then he
turned around out of the blue was like
whoa what's I like oh there was a
six-foot two pugs Danny hair so Joe took
a picture of it put it on his Instagram
and I got 2,000 new followers like that
night yeah and it amazes me the power
some of these real popular social media
people have well Joe Rogan is probably
one of the biggest I mean here I mean he
has literally I mean he's the number one
I think he's the number one podcast in
the country I'm sorry who is Harland
Williams you know I was just about not
going to go back to the hotel with you
everything I thought we were going
skinny-dipping
[Laughter]
nobody's I used she's someone I don't
know if as you or someone told me and I
can't verify these numbers but someone
told me that he makes literally millions
of dollars a year from
his advertisers on his podcast what I've
heard Billy I've heard someone else told
me that he makes he makes a significant
amount of money on his pockets but he
has a three and a half hour podcast
almost every whatever it is and he gets
something like a million something
listener I think or I think I guess I
was only four or five million downloads
in episode oh my god oh my god this
coming my podcast I've never had a
sponsor or an advertiser and I don't
even want to say how many downloads I do
okay but nowhere near what he gets
that's crazy
you're close though yeah I'm club just
two or three behind yeah yeah it just
you know you got that mm that just bums
you up you're almost there buddy under
the two thousand listeners I now have
are the ones that followed me on
Instagram and I booster me on before we
go any further you have an event coming
up i most people wait till the end of
the show to plug an event i want to make
sure we get your event i am asked now
yeah I'm really excited because I'm
going in and I can really use all the
fan support I'm going to be in Reno Reno
Nevada at the Reno Tahoe comedy club
okay and it's in its downtown and it's
Reno Tahoe comedies what it's called
what they I guess 3rd through the 5th
Thursday Friday Saturday night and there
and it's the same weekend as the PGA
Tour event in Reno so there'll be if
your golf fan if you're not a golf fan
you just like nice polo shirts come to
the show there'll be a lot of golfers
there will be a lot of fun it's going to
be a blast I'm really looking forward to
it this it's my first time at this club
so is it a new club it's not a new club
it's been around a little while they get
some good people Chris Farley's come I
think up there this weekend or not Chris
Farley uh I would be really that's a
pretty good club get Chris Farley which
is bright his Wow how about John Belushi
is he doing under the opening no but
Robin Williams might I do oh that is a
good club I are going to do papads
nobody I'm dead
butt of his brother for Farley's brother
Charlie's brother
yeah damn it that's just not right it's
not right that they then
but but he's a nice guy and he's a good
comic but so I'll be there August 3rd to
the 5th
reno/tahoe comedy you can go to my
Instagram and see that the comedy club
or Twitter whatever you you know
whatever your and you might get 2,000
extra hits on your own Instagram at
which you go to courts I mean I'm
telling you
well good buddy we will remind people at
the end of the show about I appreciate
it we want to fill that sucker up but
for now let's jump into this podcast for
the Gulf and pleasantry and late night
hotel talk let's get right to your your
interview here oh this is an interview
yeah that what we just did is the
pre-interview okay that was me just
seeing if you were kind of ready and
well know if your vocal skills were good
and I just say to begin with that you
make your guests very comfortable and in
the fact that I feel like I'm in a more
comfortable chair than you are you are I
am I am Roger by the way thank you for
that Roger you can see Roger through the
glass he's my producer say say I had a
quart Roger there he is
yeah looks like a cactus to me yeah he
needs to shave let's go you're my first
question bro what is the most hated
feature on a girl for you I mean
everyone's always are you a tea and a
guy those are the good features but I
want to know what the most hated feature
is what is it on a girl that just makes
you go oh like you don't like um I don't
like really weird like goofy hands or
feet two feet yeah like a clown and well
I mean have you ever seen like though
you ever seen a girl that has like
really long toes or so it's like like
like and I and God bless you if you got
long toes you didn't choose to have long
toes but you know socket socket it's
gotta put a sock on maybe up maybe a
boot or something even when you're
invading the well I don't know about
that but I mean cut item item by item or
earlier you talking lately
yuto's that could like open a pickle
yeah like real or pick up a fire log and
put it in the fire bacala yeah something
that like hangs over a sandal oh my god
yeah you know I mean like like they grip
the floor on ya edge of the sandal and
actually it's not bad it's not bad if
they don't if they're not because girls
like that should never wear high heels
yeah because if they do then their toes
get all jacked up
then they got corns and stuff all over
then you've got these like jacked-up
feet and it's like and that's just
something I just a little I didn't be
weird if you're wearing heels because
your foots up at an end you could
technically step on your own toes
exactly if they hung over to 400 percent
100% and and long fingers I don't mean
it like you're really short like like or
like number ones like dublin's or like
like women should have nice hands they
should yeah should have now what do we
do with the ones that don't so they'd be
executed or what do we get a little
victim hooks now have you [ __ ]
obviously you've been out what we won't
mention any I'm going to give an out
with some girls with Noblin I wear
monkey I went out with a girl wants that
had nub nubby hands yeah in monkey feet
you know all together
she had like long like it was really
weird like it was just this weird
looking thing and so it was like God was
like I'll give you long toes but I'm
gonna have to take the extra meat from
your finger I think so I don't know what
it's like
or maybe she got her toes stretched him
on her toes got pulled her finger sucked
bad or no I don't know it was odd but
I'm but I've only been like I mean
that's the foot thing is a big the foot
things much more than the hand thing did
really yeah I just it just like grosses
you out it's a turn-off sure enough you
could like see a chick in a bikini she's
hot and you're like oh man I'd like to
get with her and then you look down and
see like you know orangutan toes and
you're like oh well path or just feet
that look like they just like hammer
toes you know what's a hammer
they just got corns all over they look
like they do
and you know it is a corn of corns like
a bunion or like a you know like a giant
bump yeah like a giant bump I don't know
if I've ever seen a girl yeah
dude they're there oh yeah can you
butter them or anything girly and butter
buddy okay I did see that I thought it
was look like the fun that might be one
of the funniest things you've ever said
dude I don't know why it just make me
glad what what do you think goofy and
see yeah I don't know why that makes me
laugh it's just goofy like like somehow
God gave her clown part all right let's
move on
good answer what is your most a key
moment with a bug a spider a rodent like
everybody's had that moment where and
whether you're afraid of them or not
like there's certain times I've had
moments where abiders crawled on me in
my sleep and stuff like like what's your
ultimate icky moment I was I was in
Santa Fe New Mexico and I was living in
this I was living in this old old house
like this 200 year old house great adobe
house friend of mine was like a costume
designer at the at the Santa Fe Opera
scroll sauna she was really cool what
was her name
Donna Donna Donna she the greatest she
was like a casa she was a costume
designer for a Robert Altman and she did
a lot of movies and stuff long toes or
short short toes okay toes yeah just a
good friend just today and and Donna and
I shared a house and and and I was
staying there for I stayed there for
like six months I was just kind of like
one to get out of LA and I and I went to
Santa Fe no staying there for a while
beautiful and so I had a futon you know
in the bedroom in my bedroom it was on
the ground oh well you know can I say
I'm I don't know the answer but I know
New Mexico's like scorpion and tarantula
territory but yeah so on so one night
one night I was there and I was and I
was asleep you know I was kind of sound
asleep and I kind of felt something on
my foot I kind of felt something on my
foot and I didn't know what it was and
and I
what if it was Donna's long toes grandma
she doesn't have long ham but that would
have been that would have been well okay
so something's on your sunblock foot so
I kind of just slapped the blanket you
know and then I 30 I pull the blankets
back and it's like about a I don't know
it's about 18 inch long centipede come
on black
Sanofi like a lot like onion long
finicky he's like laying there upside
down and it freaked me out you know so I
go to get something to scoop it up to
throw away I think I killed it you know
I go to scoop something up it flips over
runs underneath my pillow
Oh dan runs up to the bed underneath my
pillow I search for that thing for an
hour and a half couldn't find it
anywhere
oh no couldn't sleep yeah you can sleep
after a 16 inch black yeah centipede
didn't sleep all night you probably
couldn't even slap the blanket off
because I still have two blanket and the
next day I went to Home Depot got some
cinder blocks and plywood and put that
bad about four feet off the car dude you
know they have like a hundred and eighty
legs they can climb well but think they
won't go up they couldn't have gone up
they couldn't have gone underneath and
upside down across the plywood Wow I
agree ever see it again ever saw it
again creeped me out man
freaked me out and those big ones too
like and it was probably what yeah yeah
it was it was like about an it was
almost it was a little bit more than it
was almost an inch wide and it was at
least 12 inches long I've watched I'm a
nature show guy so I know that those
centipedes have poison in them oh and
they actually attack small mice and
they'll actually attack scorpions
they're very aggressive they're
aggressive hunters I've watched why I've
seen them like go after a mouse like I'm
so glad insect-eating a mammal like that
I'm just so glad to talk to you after
that incident because yeah freak and I
mean I literally put that bed i greased
the bottom of the plywood before I put
it on the before I put it on the thing
like I put like so you slap the blanket
and you grease the plywood yep Wow dude
we're breaking it marry the wood yeah
you were busy in that room well you know
it's it's crazy because you know all I
can think about is where the hell did it
go well if you turn on the lights
right after you saw it yeah and it
doesn't sound like you had a ton of
furniture in that room no but I think
what it did was because I lived in this
really old house and I think it went
through the crack one of the cracks of
all the walls or you know down on the
thing I mean it just I mean I literally
shook out all the blankets pulled the
bed up took the bed put it in the other
room while I searched through you know
and just could Donna hear all this
through the water legs out if you think
he was lapping the blanket she was never
you know what's funny is I was there for
six months and she was there for like
three days of the entire six months I
was there why she was working on his
movie out of town Wow
I wonder if she thought this is just a
scenario you can you can ask her go
ahead maybe someone overstayed their
welcome and maybe Donna didn't know how
to plight Li say hey you know Cordy it's
maybe time you headed back to LA maybe
Donna in the middle of the night opened
a little jar and let mr. Crawley the
black tarantula wasp or whatever the
hell it was into your room you would
think that would be the case but
actually she was very sad to see me go
because I was paying the rent while she
while she wasn't there I don't know
sounds like she's in the entertainment
probably a bit of an actress no my
daughter no she did she act sad or no
okay
there weren't any little there weren't a
hundred and twenty little footprints on
her cosmetic counter in the knew and the
dust burning anger okay all right well
that was a great story Jay sir wow I
would say I didn't expect a I thought
maybe a spider a cockroach I did not
expect a giant centipede I mean I could
tell you the other one when I did
mushrooms and saw cockroaches in the
cabinet will say that for another one
save that for another night buddy
oh my god um this is this is a quickie
oh yeah this is
a quickie answer and you can pick the
answer here see if you you know just a
quickie if you were to stare into a full
of clips of the Sun while driving an
18-wheeler Walmart truck would you kill
a know people V between 10 and 40 people
see as many people as who live in
southern Cambodia
it's a quickie you know but I'm weighing
those Cambodians right now do they play
golf some do but they play with sticks
they don't have good clubs but do they
play on the same golf courses i play on
no no that changes my answer okay that
Lyman ago none nopey mopey okay I don't
understand people what turns court
McCowan off on a first date you're on a
first date and you're thinking oh I met
this gorgeous chick here we go I've been
distant this could be the dream girl you
get out to a nice dinner a ball game
wherever you go and she does that one
thing where you just like deal-breaker
did not need to see that talks about her
ex-boyfriend all right right talks about
the ex-boyfriend and a lot right enough
just enough to make it for you to go
you're not over this guy this is this is
a waste of my time oh that's so annoying
- or or the other one is the other one
before you go to the next one let me ask
you this if she leads into talking about
the boyfriend does that kind of pull you
into talking about the ex-girlfriend no
did you just let her let the air out of
her blown like just I try to change the
subject immediately and if they bring it
back you're like this ain't happenin
please really and you make her pay
of course okay I don't make her pay but
should make the we should there should
be an official rule they talk about the
boyfriend you build a boyfriend
the ex-boyfriend there's so many red
flags nowadays that you can kind of pick
up on yeah let's say I went to dinner
with this girl and I called her up and
said I made reservations at an Italian
place yeah
and and instead of instead of her going
oh that sounds thank you that sounds
great I'm looking forward to dinner she
was like she named a very nice expensive
high-end Italian place and I was in she
goes is it this place and I go no it's
this place and she's like oh she doesn't
like the Olive Garden well it was
Applebee's if you consider that Italian
no I hear you do that I've done that
where I've like I've like you know a
first date and I'm like Annie anywhere
you'd like to go you know grab drinks
we'll grab dinner and they're like oh
yeah like let's go to Morton's yeah man
oh yeah I know it's expensive but I'm
worth it chuckle lol and I'm like you
know I don't know what you're worth or
what you're not work but ain't taking
you there no Sonny send me a pic really
you know is it really worth it let's see
but that's the thing you're running the
gamble of let's say you do go oh wow
okay I'll take her up for a $300 dinner
at Morton's or maestro's and then you're
sitting there and you're thinking oh
this is great and she starts talking
about the ex-boyfriend and you're like
what have I just walked into well I I
don't even know that it's like it's not
even really about the money part of it
as much as it's about the like what is
this the kind of person like I I don't
like I don't like that kind of person I
don't like I want someone that's just as
comfortable going to Wahoo's Fish Tacos
yes they are going to Mastro's so if
we're getting to know each other on a
first date shouldn't matter shouldn't
matter it's all about looking in the
eyes but feelings vibes if you click on
that and then if you feel good about
that person then you maybe up the ante
yeah go somewhere else that's a good one
man I totally I totally agree with you
on that one and they can't and they
can't dislike Mexican food if they
really dislike Mexicans you love Mexican
peasant loves Mexican I didn't know this
oh yeah love now calm just think it's
great food see I too like Mexican food
but my issue is
I find like whether I order a gordita or
a float ARRA or a bandido or oh Lord oh
yeah yeah I feel like I'm getting a flat
thing with gooey beans melted cheese and
rice and sour cream like no matter what
they call it it always feels like I'm
kind of getting the same thing you're
going to the wrong Mexican restaurant
that's why because there are some
especially in this town way more so in
this town in any town I've ever been in
maybe unless you're in Texas or
somewhere okay or it is there are places
here there's a place on Beverly and I
don't even know the name of it I think
it's called mercado maybe but Evan I
just say that what's there not one of
the dishes I said I don't think so okay
but it's like everything is ala carte so
you're in it's like 250 for two little
tacos or 250 for these shrimp tacos and
then there's guacamole whatever it is
everything's like ala carte it's not
that expensive I think two people for
dinner is like 40 or 50 bucks and you
bring your own booze in you can bring in
your own wine and beer whatever you're
not at a picnic dude this is so the food
is so lean
I like this term a la carte because it's
it's like really fancy it's like French
Allah and then you get the cart which to
me always sounds like some guy you know
serving you a hot dog out of a wagon at
the back of a football stadium so have
you got a good hot dog on a cart
yeah Allah Allah Allah Allah Kabbalah
hard yeah anyways well okay I didn't
know you liked a Mexican food int result
x picture okay cool well I think we got
to move on on that right as you know
courts a comedian we're going to play a
track from your latest album that what
was it called the red all live from
Pearl Street live from Pearl Street it's
like yeah the covers all ready yeah
that's why I'm thinking red so which is
it alright if we play a traveling the
show we'll play a track but before we do
that you know
comedians stand-ups we're always working
on new bits we're always on stage that's
why we go up during the week and we do
like 10 or 15
Dean minutes pots at the local comedy
club because we have to work on new bits
and it's safe to say that all of us have
new bits going all the time so if you're
ok with it whether it's completely
polished or it's a diamond in the rough
what's the latest bit the newest
freshers bit and of course it if that
you're working on it it's not completely
refined yet but can you tell us your
latest newest bit the one I'm working on
right now that's way unfinished and I
cannot find an ending for it the opening
is great
all right maybe we'll find it right now
the opening is have you ever been watch
Netflix everybody's watching I go I just
binge watch Netflix for nine hours yeah
and I eight and a half hours in I was
like what a piece of crap show this is
yeah but I continued to watch it right
all right and I watch this show called
called the world's toughest prisons and
and it's this guy Paul Connolly who's
English and and I was in this guy's like
supposed to be this documentarian and
I've seen MSNBC lockup I've seen some
prison shows yeah yeah so I was
expecting this to be like the world's
toughest prisons I'm going to see like
like yard fight maybe somebody get
shivved in the showers of rape on some
shower rape I was going to finish our
rape but I was trying to stay away from
rapes but so I said shower shift
Oh shower Shiv Shiv dead shower but if
we're going to be real about prison if
you're watching a show called the
world's toughest prison think you got us
to throw some rape shower rape and but
there was nothing there was nothing I
mean it was literally like an interview
show of these prisons and he actually
goes in there English on top no he's
English oh he's English but they went to
like danly prison in Honduras because I
can't imagine like British prisoners
like yeah launched him in the face and
then lod beat him up yeah and then I
murdered him and then we had like a cup
of tea and I said thanks for letting me
murder you can I come back tomorrow and
murder your mum yeah these are I'm into
my solitary coz I called him a [ __ ] that
you mind if I give you an old shower
raping
what you want bending over my but this
guy actually goes goes to Honduras doors
to danly prison Honduras which when you
Dan Lee and Lee when you wanna base
ballplayer not yet
okay you go through the gate and the
last gate you go through there's no more
guards it the whole prison is run by the
prisoners oh that's smart yeah so but
the guy walks in sounds like Washington
yeah oh but this guy's gotta like he's
got a PBS camera crew so he's got like
this huge camera with like a boom mic
and I was walking through the prison
yard and he's like oh my god why are
they all looking at me it's like it's
because you got a big camera [ __ ]
yeah the last time these guys saw camera
it was tiny and it was in the corner of
a convenience store if they would have
seen that camera they probably wouldn't
be in here to begin with that's true so
so he keeps going to all these prisons
in well and basically he goes to nine
different prisons he gets nine different
cavity searches by the way oh that's why
you did the show why that's what I'm
saying I think he just did it for the
cavity search oh hell yeah yeah so every
time he goes in someplace he's like well
this is we're going to go in and they're
gonna have to search it's like of course
they're going to search you've got a new
guy putting his hands up your ass which
is that so which is like so obvious but
finally and the only reason I watched
the last half-hour is he finally goes to
this prison in Mexico El Hondo prison oh
great Mexican Russia in the Mexican food
Mexicans don't care about the camera oh
really they don't care about the camera
so most of these guys are in there for
the rest of their lives and he literally
goes into one of his bunks and he's in
the bunk and evidently they wouldn't let
the camera come into the bunk
you know wouldn't let the other guy been
there so they're filming from like
outside further way you just hear his
camera like underneath his shirt here
and go get me the [ __ ] out of here woah
so yeah it was a little El Hondo was no
so good
oh there was a black centipede arose
that bombed in there man is so what's
the part where's the ending that you're
not fighting n9ne I know I mean I that's
it but I just don't know if it's I know
I don't find it like the first line this
gets a great laugh and the rest just
kind of get huh I see I see so you're
looking for a way to tie together as a
whole I don't know the ending have to be
on the binge-watching element or the gel
LM I don't know I got a store it's just
it's just one of those things where you
just got to keep and I and then the
other thing I've been adding to it
because it's like you know every bit
Netflix once just wants us to binge
watch they want you know what maybe
that's your ending it's like you know
binge watching takes a lot of time so
you know or a good place to binge watch
is in [ __ ] jail so I won't out rob the
store just so I can [ __ ] get in a Cell
a binge watch for the next three years
that's a possibility or something I
don't have it yeah just trying to help
Brian oh you know we please don't put a
black centipede in my bed my favorite
thing when I was a kid man my favorite
thing to do is go to County Fair
the County Fair it was so [ __ ] cool
it's like when your kid it's like our
Disney man you know but like I said it
this way [ __ ] Disneyland man I got
kicked out every smokin weed it's a
small world and no idea stammers enjoy
like packing a one-hitter like it L
where L them like get the [ __ ] out of
here
it's a ripoff anyway man it you've been
you spend like $500 in Disneyland you
leave there with a paper hat with ears
your name misspelled across the front
you know but the County Fair
County Fair was kind of a ripoff two men
they used to promise you all that [ __ ]
man
very used to walk down the Midway you
have your girl when you walk down the
Midway you see that great big panda bear
attacked on the wall you're never gonna
win that panda bear it's been there
since 1962 don't win that panda bear I
was I was like throw knocking over milk
cartons you sit there knock over the
book I knocked over milk cartons for 45
minutes I didn't miss one [ __ ] milk
carton and I spent about a hundred and
forty five dollars did I get the
Panamera [ __ ] no I got a ceramic menudo
piggy bank but you've got to play the
games man there's so much fun there's
one game I'm addicted to it's a game
where you sit on the stool you grab a
squirt gun yeah and you shoot into a
clown's about the total impulse you know
that game I [ __ ] love that game I
never win I've never won is that game I
consider bunny ever won a second yeah
don't [ __ ] yourself all right
never win and I'm good
I sit down like close that I hit the
back of that classroom like a jenna
jameson video I I don't even touch the
lips I'm just like horror stuff like
that suck on that focus but then you see
that balloon going on man you're like
Pocky [ __ ] pop you want that that's a
magic balloon all right you'll hear a
pop look on the end there some [ __ ]
kid with the lazy eye or everybody's wet
is this [ __ ] like makin it like you
got to love that kid though man
he's so happy never seen that kid
walking away with that framed picture of
Al just [ __ ] happiest man gotta love
you man but the fair's cool man the
pears cool if you ever go to a county
fairs do yourself a favor
ride the rides you got to ride the rides
because they will scare the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of there
you've got a Six Flags Magic Mountain
man you go on those rides they spend
millions of dollars building these
things they're like named after
superhero you got to be this tall or
whatever it is you gotta sign insurance
forms give blood you know whatever it is
and then you sit down and these things
they put a cape and a mask on you and
they strap you in like you are going to
jump out of a goddamn airplane right and
you take off like 200 miles an hour
you're like upside-down going [ __ ] yeah
I'm not going to die on this ride right
to tilt the world the county fairs on
come on you got a 50/50 shot of getting
out there with wonder women you don't
they put you in a rusty cup filter like
1812 there's no seat belt they just
throw a string across you do you ever
see the guy that runs our run it's
rebuilding Bob from swing blade let's
get it on board
like sitting on [ __ ] guys and drive
there's one right I was on then I will
never forget this as long as I live I
was with this girl
I was about 13 14 years of this girl I
gave her the name of if you go stand in
this thing
and the thing spins around and around
and around Gravitron that's it and the
floor drops out into the wall not that
scary until a guy next to you throws up
I am on this day there's a chunk of a
chorizo in tickets waste or I'm
screaming like a little girl and you
can't move your stuff to suck the ball
so I end up with this meat pillow behind
my head here's coming Elma game never
saw that girl again never saw her um
what's your favorite famous quote could
be from a politician could be from the
Bible could be from could be from an
[ __ ] but what's you you know you know
these all the famous because like mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall like if
you have a favorite I think one of my
favorites is uh from Blazing Saddles oh
cool I love that movie Cleavon little
and he walks in and he goes where all
the white women at what why is that and
tell me why though it's just something
about it was just one of those things
when I mean I've seen Blazing Saddles
probably a hundred times it's my
favorite comedy and and just something
about on a white women at yeah because
he walks in and it's just you know is he
the lead guy the lead yeah he's a
sheriff yeah yeah you know what it's
funny you say that because he hasn't
there's a quote he did in that that's
always stayed in my head I haven't
watched that movie as much as you
probably seen it like four times but I
always remember there's a scene where
he's got all the townspeople around them
yeah and they're all waiting for him to
do something and he goes excuse me while
I whip this out and he reaches into his
pant and ever all the women are like oh
and he pulls a letter out of his pants
but I always remember scuse me while I
whip this out he was that is one of the
all-time funniest scenes ever in a movie
because it's where he's coming to become
the sheriff of Rock Ridge yeah and they
have the Welcome Wagon out they have the
band playing they have this this big
like you know sign that says welcome
Sheriff yeah and then you know and then
the guy you know you're and we she doing
a boy you know
yeah is on top of like a slim pickins
arrival in Pickens it's another guy but
he's the town drunk is on top of the on
top of the thing and he comes riding up
with Gucci saddlebag and you know the
whole thing you know the horse he
stressed all the nines and everything
and he's you know been made the sheriff
and this is you know basically when you
know slaves had just been freed know
right right and and so he rides up in
the guys on top and he's like the
sheriff and they you know they they got
the band playing goes a sheriff is a
thing rings you know yeah so they keep
using the n-word and they just keep you
know they keep doing it and then when he
rides up everybody the band stops the
sign goes up and everything like that
and that's when he does the you know
they could excuse me while I whip this
out and every was aa what whatever
happened to that actor like I don't
remember seeing him in any oh right off
to that movie he died he died of AIDS
actually believe it or not really yeah
because I never I don't remember seeing
him in another movie OD out of Blazing
Saddles did uh I want to say he did a TV
series called ten-speed and brown shoe
okay which was like you know Inglis
which was like I don't like to kill them
right there well you have a catch TV
show and OPM like Turner and hooch or BJ
in the bear or
sugar mountain and brown shoe or
whatever you said that you might as well
just jump off a cliff yeah he was I mean
you know with money up is that was that
was supposed to be Richard Pryor wanted
to play that role oh really
well Richard Pryor co-wrote co-wrote the
Blazing Saddles with Mel Brooks oh he
did yeah so that was why he didn't play
it I get a one studio didn't want him
studios what is studios now
yeah the studio didn't want him wouldn't
allow him that wouldn't allow him to do
it but he's uh he's credit is one of the
writers of Blazing Saddles that's great
let's see that's a cool quote and it led
to a lot more information that I did not
know about others yes sir know me while
I whisk you to me when I whip this out
where all the white women in ah this is
a yes or no answer so yes no I'm sorry
oh wait you gotta wait for the question
broseph whoa bro uh we know she sells
seashells by the seashore but does she
also sell freshly squeezed pineapple
juice by the seashore yes correct
all right and that leads us to the end
of the show where we play our game our
famous game that we play with all the
Heartland highway guests too soon or not
too soon have you played this game if I
have not played this game so how it
works is you have two answers too soon
or not too soon but we always suggest
that our players try to answer the
question in the best instead of just say
too soon or not too soon the more
inflection like too soon you know people
say it like fluid orden or not too soon
you know what I mean so so the more you
put into your answer it could be the
difference I've got more questions too
soon or not too soon as the answer are
you ready court McGowan to play too soon
or not too soon not too soon ha ha ha ha
here we go question number one for court
McGowan proctologists are required to
wear police-issue body cams too soon or
not too soon too soon
correct court McGowan gets his first one
right
second question Golden Corral buffets
which have an all-you-can-eat policy now
include you can eat the fattest person
in the restaurant too too soon or not
too soon not too soon
wrong that is incorrect
the answer is too soon
that's all right you're one you're one
for one let's go to question number
three there's two more pelicans and
seabirds that land in oil slicks and
turn black should be lit on fire and
used as torches by villagers who are
chasing monsters too soon or not too
soon not too soon that is not correct
why that is wrong hey yes yes you're
down to your last question the best you
can do is tie you can lose or tie
bathtub fart bubbles should be frozen
and given to children at Halloween as a
new candy called
our Spall's true there's too soon or not
too soon not too soon ha ha what Oh
George you only go one you live in two
perfect world my friend the key to this
game is every answer is two and you've
got three where you said not to zoom
well you got one it was a valiant effort
ah court before we go tell us once more
about your your gig in August oh yeah
August 3rd through the 5th
Reno Tom to Reno Tahoe comedy club you
can go to court McAllen cor TMCC Oh W n
it's at court McAllen on Instagram
Twitter Facebook all of those yeah I'll
have it all listed there where you can
get tickets and we'll even you know if
you mention the Harlan Highway I might
even be able to comp a couple tickets
for tonight
good good good deal how about that mmm i
Bateman pounders special deal and real
quick tell us where they can find your
latest stand-up comedy album they can go
to iTunes or they can go to all things
comedy calm
and it's on their wreck on their album
span it's called once more live from
Pearl Street it is a great great great
album and is it cool as we go out just
after we say goodbye can we play one
more clip from a couple absolutely folks
you gotta pick up this album it is
amazing it court recorded this live it's
just it it's fantastic
um and then lastly buddy before we go
you have a podcast of your own tell us
about that the name of the podcast is in
sensitivity training mm-hmm and it's
just and I'm going to actually try to
get you to be a guest on it soon I'll be
honored I would be honored it's not too
soon yeah correct correct
and it's at on all things comedy network
as well as the harlot I way they were on
the same network well folks this has
been court McGowan court anything you
want to say to the pavement pounders
before you sign off have you mentioned
Carmel yet on this I have talked about
Carmel but this is about you is there
anything Court McGowan wants to say
about life about the world just a
closing statement just a big fan of
horrible for caramel corn the Pug my
comedy special court actually worked on
it with me he was he was opening and did
a bunch of the skits and just helped
coordinate the whole day it was so
fantastic good night as you know from
listening to the pockets that's going to
be coming up soon we're actually editing
it right now and and a lot of fun and
thank you again for helping me with her
court buddy I had the time of my life
again I look and I will tell you as a
fan of Harlem's we've worked together
for 10 plus years yeah that was one of
the funnest nights of comedy I've ever
had in my life I was so much fun yeah we
did so as well as taping he is a pug
doing stand-up we taped a bunch of skits
court was in putting me with me in the
in the green room and we taped a bunch
of skit there and then we did some stuff
yet so when you see the special you'll
also see court there but for now let's
throw to court doing his stuff live on
stage court thanks for being on the
Harlan Highway buddy thanks fudge ladies
gentlemen Court McGowan live but I'll
tell you about myself I'm from Oklahoma
that way top you can tell a lot about a
state just by their model every state in
our great nation has a model did you
know that like the greatest bottle is
from the smallest state New Hampshire
their motto live free or [ __ ] die
that's badass probably why it's such a
small state could you not I mean
I mean even Arkansas shitty state great
model their motto is people rule I know
they need watch people but still pretty
good motto is anyone from Jersey yeah
it'll chill
but they call Jersey the Garden State
but there's not a garden in New Jersey
but you people drive you drive in
Oklahoma we don't even try our motto is
Oklahoma is okay who's on that nobody
from tourism thought that up you don't
see a bunch of people aligned in here or
go let's go to Oklahoma
it's okay we need a new bottom we need
one and I thought of the greatest model
ever and I'll tell you guys but before I
tell you you've got to realize this
Oklahoma is where the Five Civilized
tribes settled and one time the whole
state Indian Territory sketchy there's a
new oh we take reservations
[Applause]
that's badass that will get people not
Indian but will get people there you go
Corp Macau and little blur guns and
snigdha bleedin Jia what a great guest
great to have court please pick up his
album if you liked what you heard
there's a lot more of that on his album
on iTunes court McCowan and check out
his podcast and there you go as far as
I'm doing stand-up comedy it does not
start until
the fall so you can look for me around
the end of September if you go on my
website Harland Williams dot-com you
will find my links to all my stand-up
comedy shows let's see what do we got
going first oh my god I think we're
going all the way out to Portland Oregon
or Oregon or origami or whatever it is
Portland Oregon September 21st to the
24th at helium comedy club great club
get your tickets at Harlan Williams calm
then September 28th to October 1st I'm
in Chicago the Windy City and Schaumburg
and then in later in October I'll be in
Irvine California than in November I'll
be in Buffalo at the helium comedy club
then I'm back down in San Jose
California then I go back up to Canada
to Edmonton Alberta oh my god so all
these dates check and see if I'm in a
city near you right Harlan Williams calm
while you're there check out our store
we have wonderful merchandise for sale
we'll ship it to you also you can join
our Premium Membership for $20.00 a year
you get all kinds of bonus material and
every episode of the Harland highway
ever recorded 20 bucks man
that's all it costs for all that
entertainment also you can write me at
Harlan Williams com there is a contact
link there if you want to send me an
email or if you'd rather leave a voice
message three to three seven three nine
forty three thirty three to three seven
thirty nine forty three thirty you can
leave any message you want and I love
hearing from you maybe I'll put you up
on the show on the show that's it man
that's all we have time for today get
our free app on your App Store the
Heartland highway podcast listen to us
wherever you may be in jail fishing
riding a unicycle scaling a giant
redwood tree I don't know where you go
or what you do but that's why I like you
that's it also a bonus no check out my
buddy Michael Rosenbaum one of my best
buddies has a new podcast called inside
of you and he just interviewed me on his
podcast that's on iTunes inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum and cool stuff
man
so there you go ah thanks for being here
everybody and until next time
chicken chow nee baby